one of call of duty league's biggest
stars its 2020
champion hook admitted in a video on
wednesday
to using adderall while competing
adderall has
long been a topic of discussion in
esports because of the perception that
using it
can give you an edge over the
competition but
it's 2021 and it's still a problem
so let's talk about adderall
what if reality is all a twisted dream
of some sleeping god
i don't know what that would mean
actually but it probably wouldn't stop
the fact that i have to tell you to like
the video
hit the subscribe button and ring the
notification bell so that the next time
one of these
dark reveries enters my brain and
becomes content
you'll know immediately do it so this
latest discussion around adderall began
after kyler hook garland a current
member of the la
thieves cdl team posted a video to
youtube called
my story on wednesday june 9th the video
is long
and covers a bunch of topics but one of
the things people immediately focused on
was
the admission by hook that he had been
using adderall during the 2020 call of
duty league championship
but basically i won champs and i didn't
really feel good
on the inside of course i was very
grateful for winnie
it showed that we worked hard and you
know we got the win
i felt good about that but you know
those couple days afterwards i didn't
feel good
and it was mainly because of one thing i
at the time was taking adderall
obviously coming
forward and talking about something like
this isn't easy
this is someone sharing their dependence
on a drug with the rest of the world
i saw even what it was doing to my
personality over time like i was
becoming more angry to the people i love
and
even sometimes sad and i didn't like
that honestly
and um i want to change for myself so
you know that whole offseason that's
what i focus on hook
also later said that a narrative had
developed
where after he started making healthy
changes to cut adderall out of his life
they thought he was on psychedelics he
also claimed that this psychedelic
narrative
is part of the reason that the decision
was made to bench him on dallas empire
to find out from my friend that people
have been saying that and you know
they're at parties calling me crazy
kyler
for that to be a thing and for pros to
actually believe that
i just want to like shed light on that
that's not true at all i'm okay
i'm more than okay i'm ready to play
actually by the way if anyone wants me
i'm here not now i'm just fine shortly
after hook's video
other pros and esports personalities
started posting about the drug
other cod pros like slasher and aqua
chimed in as well
noting that adderall was pervasive but
it didn't need to be
mocks a player currently playing with
the los angeles gorillas academy team
said he was three months sober from
adderall and had become dependent on it
in the past
it's notable that the cdl rules prohibit
the unauthorized use
of prescription drugs but i really doubt
any of these players will face
consequences for coming forward and
it's my opinion at least that they
shouldn't if anything they've done
activision blizzard a favor
by forcing them to address this issue
and the community is responding
positively to it
with pros like censor and dallas empire
owner
hastro praising huke's decision to talk
about this
and honestly it's traditionally been a
very taboo topic
castro also said that hook being bench
had nothing to do with the drug
narrative
and that the reasons were all gameplay
related i just wanted to come out and
address some of the
talk in the call of duty community today
uh our former player kyler
uh hook came out and made a statement um
you know regarding his history and some
of the things have been going on with
him lately and so
we also wanted to come out and make a
little video and say that
we're really proud of kyler for coming
out and making the video that he did
now let's step back a bit and talk about
the drug
itself and its history within esports
everyone's heard of adderall because
it's one of the most commonly prescribed
drugs to treat
adhd which if you don't know stands for
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
adderall is essentially a prescription
amphetamine
it's a stimulant that people take to
help them focus
among other things but nowadays adderall
use is
widespread and it's common to hear about
students
using it to help them study which has
led to an
increase in the drug's popularity and in
athletics it's basically a banned
substance
everywhere unless you have a valid
prescription and
if you didn't know help i didn't know
this before working on this script
but it's illegal to take prescription
drugs that weren't prescribed to you
in many places including the us these
drugs are prescribed due to medical need
so just because the drug was prescribed
to someone else
doesn't necessarily mean it's going to
be safe for everyone to use
in esports the drug has a long history
in different games
and one of the pivotal moments for it
came in 2015
when cs go player semphys admitted to
launders in an interview that
yeah he and the rest of c9 were on
adderall when they played at esea land
i don't even care we were all on
adderall like well i don't even give a
[ __ ]
like it was pretty obvious like if you
listen to the calms like
uh people can hate it or whatever
everyone everyone does eat
adderall at the escalante right yeah
shortly after this esl announced they
would begin drug testing for adderall
the esports integrity commission got
involved and
it was generally accepted that adderall
would no longer be a part of cs go
competition
unless of course you have a valid
prescription then in 2018
esic integrity commissioner ian smith
said that while they had tested
hundreds of players they had not had a
single test come back
positive for adderall and even more
interestingly
the number of players who had
prescriptions for adderall
was still way below the national average
we
started testing in march of 2016
at iem katowice since then we've tested
over 260 players
primarily tier one counter-strike
players but also across a range of other
games
many players have been tested many times
particularly
in tier one counter-strike
and throughout that entire process not
only have we not had a single positive
but also we've surveyed about 400
players and the results of those surveys
are
that they raise absolutely no concern
about
doping in the top levels of professional
esport
but while cs go was working to get rid
of adderall
other esports leagues seemed less
concerned
a 2018 interview conducted by shaq news
with then commissioner of the overwatch
league nate nanzer
reaffirmed the league's stance on
adderall that there was no evidence it
would make you better at overwatch
so while illegal conduct and
performance-enhancing drugs were
prohibited by the rules there would be
no testing effort
nanzer's reply then raises an
interesting question
does adderall actually improve a
player's performance
clearly there were and are a lot of
players
that believe it does but the science is
a little less conclusive
studies have been completed about the
drug's role in traditional athletics
and in academia but i wasn't able to
find one specifically about esports
performance
in an article in pc gamer from december
2020
psychiatrist william dodson pointed out
that players that see an improvement
may simply be experiencing a placebo
effect
or even potentially have undiagnosed
adhd
but whether adderall actually helps
players reach
the peak of their potential as some
people have put it
one thing seems clear developing an
addiction to adderall can have
serious negative side effects besides
things like restlessness and dry mouth
adderall can cause increased paranoia
aggression
and hostility to say nothing of the
various rare
physical side effects and when you start
taking even more than the usual dose to
try to get the same effects
things can get ugly in my opinion that's
as good a reason as any to test for it
in every esport
to protect the players who might feel
pressured to try it
to bring their performance to some
higher level the thing is esports
continues to grow
and with it we're seeing increased
potential to make money through
competing even if adderall had
zero positive effect on players there
are clearly people out there who are
willing to
try it in order to gain that competitive
edge
and if that initial attempt becomes an
addiction
it can have destructive consequences if
all leagues tested for it then
simply trying adderall and then maybe
getting addicted to it
wouldn't be an option at all whether
it's performance enhancing or not
is kind of not the point and listen i'm
one of the last people
that's going to advocate for increased
drug testing because
well maybe you caught my joke in the
last video i did
and please don't call it the after plant
meta we already have a term
for it and after plant just sounds
really weird
in any case my experience with the after
plant meta
is ordering onion rings at 1am shout out
to my local burger place come on
it's legal here get off my back if you
live somewhere that is in canada you
might be surprised to find out that
here it's pretty rare to test new
employees for drugs
in fact you basically need to be doing a
job where safety is paramount
and like habitual drug use would cause
harm to someone else
i've literally never been tested for
drugs by an employer but we're not
talking about my job at canadian
bookstore chain
chapters in 2007 we're talking about a
competition
where the rules rightfully prohibit the
use of substances
that could affect the integrity of the
games that are being played
let's agree to protect both the
competition and the bodies and minds of
young aspiring pros
and test for these substances that
should include the overwatch league
and the call of duty league hook's video
is a reminder that
there's a lot to fix in esports but
maybe
with his video these leagues will
finally realize that there are pro
players suffering under the stress of
competition
and maybe just maybe they'll do
something about it
i was like is he dutch seems like dutch
maybe but
i don't think he's dutch he's american
he's not dutch
and you know what they say if you're not
dutch you're not much
you know what they say if you're not
dutch get